what's going on guys this is rob and i'm
a little behind the times here but i
want to talk about this kind of massive
plot leak that's been going on with
regards to doctor strange too that's
still a talking point some week and a
half after it was kind of dropped now
the big talking point here is the role
that wanda plays in relation to like
schumachorath america chavez doctor
strange and even the overall role she
plays in the film so one of the big
questions a lot of people have had is
what's wanda's role in doctor strange
two going to be is she going to be the
main villain we largely assume that she
is even with the news dropping that
schuma gorath will be in doctor strange
tomb then a lot of the information out
there seems to indicate he'll be a minor
villain right something small that if we
were to look at the role loki plays in
the marvel cinematic universe in the
first avengers movie side by side with
like the bigger threat of thanos with
regards to the infinity gauntlet that's
kind of what we're looking at here right
that schuma gorath would be like
something akin to loki kind of the
smaller threat and that the big threat
the main overarching villain behind all
this is wanda but the big question that
we've always kind of had ever since the
shumogorath news was dropped is
what role would schuma gorath have here
why would he even be in the mcu in the
first place so what this bit of news
reveals is that apparently by some form
or fashion wanda essentially summons
schuma gorath now this is kind of the
weird thing here is because shumagorath
is one of these characters at least in
the comics anyway where he exists out
there in the multiverse right the main
marvel universe in the comics and
presumably the marvel cinematic universe
if you want to go in that direction is
basically just the next step in what it
is that he's trying to conquer right so
if we looked at it as some kind of like
an earth-based empire it would be like
somebody conquering like britain and
then france and then russia and so on
and so forth and finally making their
way to the states it's just the next
step in the campaign they have to try to
conquer everything shumogorath rules
whole universes in the multiverse right
just entire swaths of the multiverse
belong to shumogorath but in the marvel
cinematic universe it seems to be a
wholly different game whether
shumogorath is just some kind of demonic
entity that exists out there or whatever
the case is it seems to be one of these
things where wanda is trying to attain
schumacher now the question is why and
the linchpin behind all this is the
statement agatha harkness made to wanda
during one division so if you guys
recall in juan division there's that
scene where agatha has the kids of wanda
right just kind of like little leashes
on them child leashes
and she makes the statement to wanda
that she is the scarlet witch right
she's destined to become that character
the scarlet witch is kind of a concept
right just this being that's capable of
spontaneous creation and is destined to
become more powerful than the sorcerer
supreme and so if you link these two
things together it's entirely possible
that in the mcu shumogorath doesn't
exist yet and shimogorath doesn't exist
yet because wanda has not created schuma
gorath now the big question here is why
would wanda create a being that's
capable of traveling the multiverse when
wanda herself is capable of traveling
the multiverse and i think the answer to
that question is because wanda can't do
that yet she hasn't attained that level
of power now this goes into the next
part of this theory which is that the
post-credits scene of wand division
takes place two years after the end of
the series but we don't know what it is
that the darkhold is entirely capable of
if she was studying it for two years and
learned how to create life different
things like that but hadn't quite
reached the point where it was explained
to her how to travel throughout the
multiverse or if it was something like
the book of cagliostro where the ability
to travel the multiverse was ripped out
of the pages ripped out of the book
itself then that would suddenly be
information that's not readily available
to her and this could be one of those
instances we've talked about before
where wanda approaches steven strange
for the purpose of saying i need you to
help me find my kids in the multiverse
and the response to stephen strange is
no you can't mess with the multiverse
that way which of course then begs the
question why is he doing what he's doing
and spider-man 2 no way home that's
neither here nor there the important
thing here is that if wanda feels as
though she has no other option than to
basically use her chaos magic to just
kind of create life but what she has is
raw talent without the proper training
she could essentially create shumo
gorath and then send shumogorath into
the multiverse for the purpose of
tracking down america chavez now this is
the next part of the theory here which
is really really important that america
chavez has existed in the mcu for quite
some time she's not going to be someone
who just suddenly gained the ability to
travel through the multiverse in the
beginning of doctor strange too that
instead what's been happening is she's
basically been on the run for her entire
life running from various beings various
individuals out there who are looking to
capture her power and use it for their
own ends and that wanda is basically
just the most recent version of a person
who's able to do that that wand is
looking to find her kids she ends up
creating chuma graf as a kind of demonic
being or a being that can kind of
transition or travel through the
multiverse for the purpose of finding
america chavez and then if the powers of
shumogorath are anything like they are
in the comics then he could basically
subdue the will of america chavez place
her under his control and then bring
america to wanda wanda could in turn
take america chavez's powers just from
simple power absorption spells and then
travel to the multiverse to find her
kids what will most likely happen here
if this is the case and again this is
just a theory so there's no definitive
you know reason to believe this is an
absolute truth but if this is the case
it would be highly likely that steven
strange or spider-man or any number of
the good guys who are going to be in
this film are going to come across
america chavez and save her from schuma
gorath getting in the way of wanda the
scarlet witch the biggest issue that you
have with this or at least one of the
big issues you have with this is that if
wanda's the main villain of doctor
strange too it wouldn't really make a
whole lot of sense for her to basically
be stuck and confined to earth to the
main marvel cinematic universe and not
be able to leave that universe it makes
a lot more sense that she can travel
through the multiverse by whatever
manner and whatever means meaning that
is possible she perhaps gets her hands
on america chavez and takes america's
powers or is able to siphon off some
level of her power to move on to a
higher state we saw her do that with
agatha harkness where she literally took
her abilities away right shut down her
ability to use their own powers possibly
even absorb them into herself so we've
seen this kind of precedent in the mcu
so far but again i think that wanda
transitioning into the multiverse and
becoming a multiversal threat is a far
more effective thing which really kind
of leads us back to the original
question what does schumachura's have to
do with this and the most likely
scenario here is wanda's just that damn
powerful that shumagorath is a very
powerful being a very capable being but
wanda is just that much more powerful
than he is and so the reality is because
shumogorath is essentially just this
being that's looking to track down
america chavez that perhaps wanda just
sees his control of shumogorath and he
basically serves as her kind of lap dog
but again why would wanda need someone
to travel the multiverse for her in
order to find america chavez if she
could do that herself and why would she
even need america chavez if she can
travel the multiverse now the next big
information drop that came to us is
basically professor x and doctor strange
two the multiverse of madness now this
is not new per se right this rumor's
been going around for quite some time
but an image that leaked on twitter
recently shows us what professor x would
presumably look like in doctor strange
too now the other rumor that kind of
goes along with this is the whole
illuminati thing those of you guys who
don't know what that is that's basically
a group of what are in effect the most
powerful members or leaders of superhero
groups that exist out there that kind of
operate behind the scenes right they
were originally introduced by brian
michael bendis and marvel comics and
have played some pretty significant
roles over the years more recently with
the collapse of the multiverse which is
pretty fitting considering everything
going on in doctor strange too but the
important thing is that according to
these leaks this group exists out there
in the multiverse they're not really a
multiversal group they just exist in a
universe out there and that what's going
to happen is that somewhere over the
course of the film dr strange is going
to stumble across their universe and
because he's someone who's not from that
particular earth specifically from that
particular universe most likely because
they already have their own version of
doctor strange he'll be captured and
brought before the group and that's when
we'll get the introduction to them now
what significance they will have overall
in the film is anybody's guess if i'm a
betting man given the fact that this
film does not have like a five hour run
time
and it's not split into two parts i
would say if they do up here it's gonna
be small it's gonna be a quick momentary
thing that'll last maybe ten minutes at
most and then it's on to the races you
know back into the the whole rigmar and
everything going on with the rest of the
movie having said that this is a huge
development because the way that it
looks is it looks like patrick stewart
and one of the big things a lot of
people are talking about is that because
of the fact that alfred molina's dr
octopus is the actual doctor octopus
from the sam raimi original sony
spider-man movies back in the early
2000s then it stands to reason this
version of professor x is actually going
to be the patrick stewart professor x
that we're all familiar with from the
fox x-men line of movies so this is cool
it's a really really interesting
development again what role is going to
play we don't fully know but it is
interesting to see having said all that
guys one thing i do want to point out
all these leaks rumors things like that
are all basically coming from the
illuminati they're coming from den of
nerds oh that's where at least i'm
getting a lot of this information from
right so we'll post links to these guys
down in the description make sure you
guys go check them out right i always
think it's important to cite our sources
here thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace